I was wondering if we could talk about
short films for a moment and you talked
about how you made your first short film
and when you look back at it now there's
things that you're really proud about it
and and so some of the misconceptions
some of these filmmakers have about
short films and it's just your opinion I
get it's not law but you know you had
some opinions about it and I would love
to hear about it yeah I mean like you
know I understand like a lot of people
um you know are very sort of like anti
short films that they want to um you
know I get this I hear these people
saying like you know no one cares about
short films and all that light you know
I mean I mean there's an Academy Award
for short films I mean like obviously
some people care about them but like I
mean but I mean like I I get what
they're saying that feature films I mean
I mean like that makes sense now I was
making sure it's four years and none of
them were going anywhere then boom I
make a feature and then again it's like
you know it gets a lot of exposure and
all that stuff so there is I understand
that but um but I wouldn't have been
able to approach the feature the way I
did if it wasn't for all those shorts
that I was making and so I think like
short films for me I started realize
over the years that they're not at all
about getting representation through
those or getting a big movie out of
those I mean like that that would there
was a time that that that happened I
still am shocked when people make like
one five minutes short that goes viral
and they get like a twenty million
dollar movie like I just don't really
understand that at all um I think you
really need to earn your stripes a
little bit and but yeah I mean III think
shorts are much more just about lying
like sculpting your aesthetic and
learning how to tell a story and working
with actors and working with like
truncated schedules and and just just
understanding how movies are made before
you jump into a feature cuz like making
a feature versus making it short I mean
it's it really is night day actually I
mean it's such a completely different
experience like you need to you need to
get there's like warm-up periods and
light and and and maybe make shorts that
are like in all five minutes than 10
minutes then maybe a 20 minutes short
like getting a little bit closer to you
know stretching out a story a little bit
more and but yeah but I think like I
don't know I mean I just um you know
everyone has their theories on things
and
I don't want to like knock anything down
but the I just don't I think when people
say I don't get I don't care about
shorts I just I just wanna I just
graduated film school I just want to
make a feature right now like that's I
hear that a lot from people and and or
people just want to make just one short
and then jump into a feature and I I
feel like I'm there like ryan johnson
said somebody who did like the newest
star wars in the day and and he was like
saying make like 30 short films if you
can like make as many mistakes as bug
because that's that's why the biggest
thing like because I think making movies
is always like just sort of like success
training experiment mess up a lot you
know just and you know I always go for
like the more like you know ambitious
projects always try to like you know
approach you know something that's hard
you know I think a lot of people get so
cautious about them I think they're
they're so afraid of failure I think
they're so afraid of they're so
terrified of like making a movie that's
maybe a little too dense or a little too
challenging for them to approach in a
you know short schedule or like no money
or something and be like I know I've
always because like I mean yeah if you
make something that's like super n-bit
and you and you you and maybe you maybe
you do totally fail but it's like I
would rather make something that's you
know ambitious and I say it challenged
me so much and trained me for like the
next movies and perhaps maybe like fail
at it then make something that's so like
just two people talking to each other
and just such a you know kind of like a
kind of an easy movie just because it's
more economically realistic maybe but
that's I don't think that's gonna like
train you like it on you know I think
III think they can train you on a
somewhat of a level but I think um I
think I think if you could if you can do
something really ambitious in a very
short schedule on a very tight budget
like like someone like Robert Rodriguez
or like you know John Carpenter like I
mean or Edgar Wright even I mean like
those are like there's like the guys
that that I like look up to they're like
they're kind of a I understand like
Rodriguez and John Carter score their
own music and do a lot of their own
stuff but it's like but their mentality
about always going for like the more
ambitious project and making about just
creating a bunch you know because I mean
John Carpenter made so many short films
like dark star and then Rodriguez made
so many short films before he made el
Mariachi and and I just think like short
films are very important to do because I
think if you completely neglect them
you're just like I almost think it's
sort of like and I think it's somewhat
disrespectful I think to to like
moviemaking because like what makes you
think you're so good to just jump into a
feature right away it's like I'm I mean
Scorsese made so many shorts even before
like who's that knocking on my door I
mean like so I mean I yeah I'm very much
like pro pro short films and then make
as many as possible and just really just
screw up as much as possible like make
as many mistakes as possible you know
cuz it's because one day you might make
that a newly weren't everything just
clicks and like but you're not gonna be
able make that movie until you make
those previous movies that you've
learned from all those mistakes and and
that's like yeah yeah I just I just I
just just don't overthink things just
keep keep creating keep making making
stuff
you